yeah I see a finish box why don't we
just have lunch talk we could do that
right what house Karen and the kids okay
they ask about you mister step up next
week and I know they'd love you see me
right no I'm just saying you're horrible
about myself I know they wanted you to
be there that's all I'm sorry dad um I
just need some money
right so please just give me my money
where does this end this is I gotta see
some through this is kind of working out
for me right now I got five days so it
doesn't look like it's working out oh it
doesn't look like it's working out sweat
then therapy huh you can come home no
that would make it work please Nick
please
I've been doing some research you do in
research you gotta be kidding me dad you
think that you have this under control
no and I understand how scared you are I
understand why I do things it doesn't
make me any different all right I'm
attracted to craziness and you're just
embarrassed because I was like you know
I was like this amazing thing like your
special creation or something and you
know like Who I am now yeah who are you
this is me dad here this is who I am
when I tried it I felt better than I
ever had so I just kept on doing it
why no I thought we were closer than
most fathers and sons this isn't us this
is not who we both of you stop
there are moments that I look at him and
I wonder who we is how's that boy David
I'm not giving up now
never
[Music]
you always gotta be controlling
everything doesn't make any sense
right now let us help you I don't want
you to help don't you understand that I
had such grand plans you'd graduate from
college do something amazing and now I
just wanted to not die who are you Nick
this isn't me that here this is Who I am
if you could take all the words in the
language it's still in describing each
other I love you more than everything
I'm really sorry it's hard as hell to
get sober but I love my family I want to
be proud of me
[Music]
I understand how scared you are little
pass though it always does
Mack what you have is extraordinary
and you're gonna get it back you're
gonna find it again
you
you